welcome to this video place a national
master rain maker from Estonia all our
zebus the name
I have played them really often I only
have half a point out of two I mean the
thing is two games is the the funny act
which is think because I have played in
many times with earlier and handles
other names oh this is crazy
what is this following him and crazy is
the wrong word it looks fairly solid for
white yeah here I can try to keep the
pawn with f5 I think I think there is an
even a video why I tried this but it
does not look right him yeah come on
that's just develop it cannot be cannot
be bad I wonder if Bishop c6 is an idea
impossible but okay
probably g6 is the right way to develop
the bishop in any case the capture
should would would really weaken the
dark square so the tax press and the
light square spec the light squares
obviously I think Anakin if I begin to
confuse light and dark squares it it is
starting to get critical let's see
whether this looks really comfortable
isn't it what about the Bishop g4 here
Bishop g4 intending 95 this looks fairly
harmonious for for black
Knight e5 Knight f3 isn't this dangerous
okay how I'm playing that let's let's
gamble I don't really think that this
can be any good night f3 really hmm but
that that is a knowing check
I can play Bishop c6 now and 25 he must
play Quincy fourth lap so all this maybe
this one but he needs to control on d5
that's that's absolutely mandatory okay
but anyway I cannot really believe that
this is any good
so Queen how do I get that Queen d7 age
three M would be something to consider
Queen d7 takes and then if five this is
very strong he five and getting the
Queen over but he has a rookie one but
Rach do you wanna have Bishop f4 okay
so then this is we move rook to e1
Bishop f4 I am winning winning the
exchange very nice okay I think this was
was good and if he takes very important
is e5 to block 94 Bishop d4 Knight f4 e
5.25 it just takes away all squares by
whites minor pieces yeah okay this looks
fine
that's very tricky I really don't know
what yeah okay not let's not waste time
him maybe he will try something like he
wrote the one Queen age three rookie
five this this type of Defense
you know this is probably his idea I
just wonder if there is any any way to
to play against against it
he always has see form protecting
protecting Queen age three rook t5 I can
I can just take it which is not bad but
it's not not winning immediately rook
the end I can I can also try to go to
every three maybe this is this is even
better so that I'm also attacking the
the night only to yeah
now I thought work the eight first and
then one like this Queen f3
rook t5 rook the aid yeah in fact he has
Knight c3
let's get match Nazi 3 if I go Bishop d7
then there's Queen d1 that yes sir he
has managed to keep keeper to to to
prevent this maid okay I need to take
that mm-hmm that's really not ideal what
the heck I mean I cannot punish this
kind of total nonsense then it gets
really annoying I mean this is just just
totally crazy giving up the LightSquared
Bishop and I'm sorry but I didn't I
didn't punish it now watch has some
points it's not not easy at all
I don't know maybe it wasn't that easy I
mean but this is not really really too
great if I get an F five King F seven
I'm okay but I didn't even see Bishop e7
maybe I get c5 then I can at least play
this should be a droopy eight Bishop c5
maybe this is possible
Jeff yeah that it I think it really was
worse at some point I mean this is not
great but I feel like I already
shouldn't have gotten down you can place
you six like check check check check
place is six all the time and he's not
doing it
check check check
check check check check check check okay
this ever drop what the beep I really
and how can this not be a forced win I
mean this is so insane this whole plane
now I don't okay okay
not of course not this if I if I looks
totally normal and they didn't want to
waste any time
but Karina five is just an instant
winner okay because ninety four I can
just take okay so he does not have those
defenses at all I don't need to prevent
them okay yeah this is minus seven or
something like this then he five yeah I
mean that this should should be
faithless not really a surprise okay
this is what I played queen G horse
maybe better yeah and around here I was
trying to be clever but it really did
wonder exchange under far less favorable
circumstances adhere I'm Angus I mean
just like that he only failed to put it
away a ton of times check it was it was
really easy many times that just was c6
for example check check check check
yeah hey this is this is really really
useless to analyze twenty seconds
yeah yeah I need to I need to really
punish this this this opening I mean
this this is just just amazing that you
can can play like that check but okay
this is see a queen f5 or queen g4 is
much stronger if five looks completely
logical but he always has this rook t5
idea maybe am this is the the the
easiest way to go about it once once I
am there I mean something like this just
just letters in the pawns and then go
for for total activity here now
threatening rookie to something like
that should be pretty pretty good the
problem is so that this pawn is totally
killing his minor pieces yeah this is
what I should have done as much easier
but trying to be clever didn't help okay
thanks for watching